hey everyone this is Kim from the chess
website calm and today we're in round 9
in potential our last round of the 2016
Singh field cup I say potentially last
because we could have a tournament going
on tomorrow Wesley so currently sitting
up top of the leaderboard by half a
point leading three competitors tied for
second right behind him with Vichy and
Anto blob and Levon Aronian so if either
those three players win Wesley so even
with the tie would go into a tournament
tomorrow now if they all draw then
Wesley so with a draw would be the
champion so in today's Matt's were gonna
be watching in DL playing the white
pieces in black being played by Wesley
so since he is in the lead always gonna
be interesting to see how he plays out
his final match into the tournament
starts out with pawn to e4 from MBL so
continues pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6
and then Bishop to b5 getting into the
right Lopez and the knight to f6 getting
into the Berlin defence and viola
castles on the King side Knight takes
down in on e4 pawn to d4 and we've been
covering the Berlin defense more and
more frequently in this variation that
you're looking at right here seems to be
pretty common now the Knights gonna come
back to d6 the bishop takes pawn takes
and then pawn takes on D or e v forcing
the knight to move and the Queen's come
off the board in this particular
variation after that pawn to d4 is
probably one of the more tallish lines
and it's interesting to note how Wesley
so feels about this he does want at
least a draw to make sure that if there
is a tie with vision on toe blob or
Aronian that he can at least get a share
potentially into the playoffs tomorrow
but you know that deep down he's playing
better chess than mvl and really like to
be playing for the victory here pawn
here to h3 and then King to e8
recognizing that rook over here to d1
controlling this deep pile just wants to
go ahead and get it out of the way right
now Knight to c3 just continuing develop
and then pawn to h5 so since he can't
castle since he's moved his king decides
to go ahead and start pushing over here
on the King side where his opponents
is usually you see this if you either a
castle on the Queen side you just start
to push all your pawns on your
opponent's king said if he's Castle
there or if you in this position once
he's already moved his king usually
after the Queen's have swapped off the
board then you start to push her pawns
the same Bishop to g5 Bishop e6 to both
sides continuing development on board
I work here to d1 just controlling this
open file a bishop here to e7 pawn here
to b3 I just flew to find the pawn chain
a little bit also allowing this Knight
to move if he wants to right now it is
guarding this pawn here on a2
pawn here to a5 so hey let's go ahead
and start to attack on the Queen side of
the board as well
rook to d3 just preparing for the rook
over here to be one if he wants to and
rook over here to d8 so we do say
exchange on board and then the rook
comes back here to d1 controlling this
open file so nvl right now has a slight
advantage just because he's controlling
a little bit more of the center of the
board his central pawns pushed a little
bit more forward and he is the only one
with a Ford a central pawn right now but
all in all Wesley so still has a pretty
good board but he doesn't have you know
one of his rooks he doesn't have his
Queen on board so it's gonna be
difficult to come up with a very strong
attack for Wesley so so takes on g5 the
knight takes on g5 and then King to e7
activating the King the Queen's off the
board the bishops are off the board is
safe to now get the King involved what's
this is gonna all the material that he
can involve into the attack if he wants
to have any sort of chance and actually
winning this game night here - E - now
that the pawn up here on b3 doesn't have
to worry about protecting the pawn on a2
with this Knights we can freely bring
his knight here to a2 and then later he
can get at bottom to the game ID here to
d4 Knight here to f4 he does have some
options on board my age four and then
pawn up to g3 forcing the knight back
the knight was really planning on coming
back anyway g6 attacking the pawn here
on e5 Knight takes and then pawn takes
right here and then pawn up here to f4
so let me find this pawn chain
protect
upon here on e5 so now brings his rook
over here to f8 the one semi-open file
that he can control you always want to
have your rooks controlling open files
or semi open files send me open file
meaning you don't have your pawn there
completely open file would be no pawns
at all so the work comes over here to f8
can't control the default sense right
now and Els controlling the D file so
rook appear to a deform wants to make
sure that he can control this fourth
rank anytime your opponent is going to
be pushing pawns over here this is a
very strong square that he can really
control this entire rank here pioneer to
c5 is going to force it to move it comes
here to e4 so can still hold on to that
material and immediately once it comes
off this D file Wesley so brings his
work over here to d8 King to f2 just
getting his King involved into the
action and then it broke down here to d1
I probably would have played rook down
here to d2 I usually like to get my
rooks to the second rank of my opponent
if I'm playing black if I'm white like
to bring it up here to the seventh rank
but all I'll decide to go and bring it
down here to d1 so you can get behind in
enemy lines with rook to a1 broke over
here to h7 does have some options right
there either way we're here to d1 or d2
it's going to be somewhat of a nuisance
for MBL to deal with pawn here to g4
looking to break things up a little bit
pawn captures on g4 and then pawn to b5
so Wesley so looking to start attacking
over here on the the Queen side of the
board punt up to f5 so NBL says hey if
you're gonna attack on the Queen side
I'll attack on the King side we do see
Knight to h4 protecting this square here
on f5 after any potential exchange and
same thing from white knight over here
to g3 protecting that same square root a
one decides to go ahead and start an
attack on the Queen side punt up here to
a 4 and then rook to a2 just improving
the position a little bit attacking both
the pawn on a 4 and this pawn here on c2
MVL takes on b5 broke over here takes on
a c2
there are double pawns so just keep that
in mind if we look at the pawns we do
see five pawns
five ponds and there's double ponds here
on the sea file double ponds here on the
B file so all pretty even on board now
the roofs come off the board fairly draw
in game someone would definitely have to
make a mistake to not have this be into
a draw
pawn down here to c4 pawn takes and then
the pond pushes over here to a4 so black
giving up material recognizing that his
really only shot on board is for nvl to
make a huge mistake or to push this pawn
that's what he starts to do pawn to a4
and essentially white has to start
bringing as king over here to protect
that King here to d3 Knight to f3 pawn
up to f6 just trying to have some sort
of attack over here on at the king side
to keep Plex attention away from this
pawn over here on a for King to f7 we do
see an exchange on board in the Knight
to e5 check King over here to c3 who's
gonna be that way anyway pawn to a3 punt
up here to a c5 does not want to go
ahead and bring his king over there
right now because then he could just
lose one of his pawns right away if we
were to see King to b3 we just need the
knight take if the King can't just take
right here because then the pawns just
gonna keep pushing forward on board so
he does have the in-between move up on
to c5 now Wesley so plays Knight to d3 a
move that a lot of amateurs may fall for
take the knight here that's clearly
gonna be bad pawn to a2 gonna be getting
ready to promote so can't do that
probably a little bit better to then the
not the King taking on g7 because now
the King just comes over here to b3
there's no real way to hold on to this
material and then there's three pawns to
two pawns and white probably has a
pretty good position on board instead he
decides to play correctly night down
here to d3
now after King to b3 the knight can take
on c5 check and after the King takes we
do have three pawns to two pawns but
it's a little bit better now the King
can take on a g7 and things are gonna be
okay for both sides of the ball
it's gonna be pre Josh King here to be
four light down here to d3 check King c4
Knight here to e5 check King moves and
then King over here to h6 so continues
after a Knight to e2 I plays pawn here
to c6 that's probably better than taking
on g4 because then we have King to c6
his Knights just not involved into the
action and he really just has to worry
about this pawn pushing forward you
can't check maybe your opponent with
just a knight so as long as he doesn't
allow his opponent to push this pawn
he's gonna be fine so instead decides
okay I'm not gonna take this pond it's
kind of a bogey over there but I'll play
pawn here to c6 try to get this pawn off
the board would you see the pawn take
and then after that the knight takes
here the King takes the novice Ed we can
see this pawn is not going to be able to
be protected by this Knight and so after
the pawn takes or the King takes the
pawn the King takes the pawn we do see a
draw on board so Wesley so gets the draw
fortunately for him Vichy and honto
Bluff and Levon Aronian all tied their
games Wesley so did have to wait to
actually make sure that that would
happen since this game ended a little
bit early but congratulations to Wesley
so played a really really good
tournament and at the end of the day you
don't always see the craziest the
matches there's no way for him to put
himself in any crazy positions going
into the last round where he does need a
draw for sure knowing that one of his
opponents will at least hit a draw but
congratulations to them really good
tournament thank you everyone for
watching Sinquefield cup always wanted
the best tournaments of the year
especially being part of the grand tour
so be on the lookout in a few months we
do have the World Championships in
November they will be held in New York
with certain gated karyakin and a magnus
carlsen defending champions that's going
to be an exciting match and then in
December we have the last leg of the
grand tour which is the London classic
so be on the lookout for that as well
but until next time thanks again for
watching